thought of that let me uh I think oh oh
wait a second I'm going to enter this
tournament time I'm gonna add term
enhancer I'm an enter Wow that was a
last-second it's two minutes war zone 96
players
30 minute tournament all right let's do
this I kind of just jumped right in here
double the points and okay Sicilian what
am I crazy playing the Sicilian I'm not
knight c6 coming up whoa they are
thinking a lot already what is going on
here are they really going to take put
pushing the pawns in a good clean check
all right been here before
slower games oh this is my preparation
this is all preparation here let's go
and now oh okay let's take there and win
upon let's win upon there we go
I'm going to take with the King because
he's going to be excited about playing
to this square this is a this is a
perfectly good square can double my
pawns these guys are going to be still
quite a wipe await this is a move I had
played before so now I'm able to kind of
rattle these off a bit a bit easier
let's do this make it a bit more
inconvenient for them to grab that pawn
double pawns two sets of double pawns
here but tricks for kirovsky coming up
on this f3 they missed that detail they
thought rook takes was going to be
getting the pawn back but it's not
so let's cement my bishop there and
challenge this rook rook takes I think
Knight here is going to turn out to be
okay well let's force this bishop into a
decision what does it want to do family
treat for a second I'm alright with this
I'm okay with giving back upon
well um let's chase this bishop around
actually oh I didn't alright let's let's
give them my rook let's see if they take
the rook because my bishops okay that's
actually pretty good there so the knight
isn't within checking distance hang on I
don't want to give that up so easily
hang on I want my knight on f4 I know
that and all right let's let's do this
first let's get my knight on f4 and then
my pawn here and then this rook is dead
to the game the rook is dead to the game
for as long as I have this structure and
this Knight is getting ready for that
pawn ah this is something's gone wrong
here um yeah I'm not like okay now I'm
like in position what's it where's this
night going the rook is dead there
because I should have got to the seventh
rank where's the night going I'm
probably gonna take it oh what a sad
position for that night to have to go to
oh that's painful right it's got to be
painful right there
King improvement I could walk my King
right over here when that rook that's
what I'm gonna do they're gonna pick off
this Knight though I can't go here let's
come over here come over here this is a
passed pawn and let's get it back up I'm
gonna get this guy back up I don't this
Knight to get out so easily let's keep
them trapped now I'm going to go after
them mate mate threat either look mate
I'll take it back to tournament 3 3 2 2
the average rating is 1713 if you're
curious you can't see that on the I
didn't mean to do that let's work with
it though let's do this
structure going for a Kings Indian
structure the stakes have been doubled
um they are not moving a non mover okay
what do you do when they don't move
don't know
yeah so what's going on elsewhere this
is the tournament is the chess cube of
meltdown if you're trying to track it
down and somebody has five they already
have two games in I'm still waiting on
number 205 has the lead this is like it
feels like an eternity to be waiting
[Music]
why do players do this
mmm one minute might as well wait the
one minute oh I'm sinking 2/10 5 4 4 3 3
3 3 3
okay I got the Primo Vaughn jeopardy
music is right who's in the chat Heiser
Jack smell card chess guevara mega King
tip breath GJ not gonna even touch that
one brash our bloodless hello and yeah I
think you got them all okay so few
seconds game over
back to tournament who's got six points
that's right
6 6 5 5 here we go I'm not going to get
paired up now let's do this come on 23
minutes left in this tournament hmm come
on here okay
Oh Kali Kali I'm not going to go for the
Sicilian this time Kali no Sicilian
advanced Cairo for you let's take this
guy I love this variation and my night
is going to love f5 he's gonna love it
here we go where's that nightgown he's
ready to challenge my night NF v g6 to
support it gain some space on the
queenside
a5 is available for my queen looking for
h3 the center is closed if it seems
ridiculous that I'm not developing you
know my king over here well don't view
it like that there's no need to there's
going to be more time to make
maneuvering type of stuff and now this
Knight is cemented in there there's no
pushing it away and if this pawn pushes
then this is a target let's take take
again and then lock down on this square
so my knight actually would love to get
back over here this Knight love to be
there how could I make that happen
I'm going to take steps to try and make
that happen also there's lateral defense
in case Knight takes I hope to take with
the pomp the pawn anymore and let's
close it up a bit more there my okay
let's um let's free time to reposition
my knight is eventually going to end up
on f6 I'm going to make that happen but
before that I want to stop out any pawn
breaks so a little delicate but we're
going to be entering a good versus bad
Bishop situation and now with this
position opening up I'm a gem time just
netting upon just give a check and then
take here okay so now I might want to
transfer my attention getting my knight
no longer to f5 but what about c4 that
seems to be a pretty good square I guess
in the meantime the Knights heading for
this I'm gonna be a bit more stubborn
maybe let's get this here my bishops
there to watch over my Knights here I'm
looking for this square if we have these
guys exchange okay I can actually throw
in a check now that my Knights around
hang on let's back up he's back up our
way are we going to end up with a
perpetual there I'm fearing a perpetual
actually
now let's do this I want to have a
connected pass pawn and okay now how do
they recapture the King okay this is
this is going to be really strong look
at the King position sneaking in here
he's running wild here King is running
wild but I have very little time here
I'm gonna welcome a discovered check
that's all right there we go I have a
third attacker now on that rook okay I
got a pawn and might want to run
okay now getting this getting the Bishop
let's take this and watch over my base
point it's the only pawn I needed to
worry about let's come here next up pawn
punish and then break down this
structure let's kick the King away first
I want them to recapture on the square
with the rook then I gobble up this guy
and threaten mate soon enough
resignation back to tournament okay
twelve my king was a running mad in that
game he's going a little nuts he got
very very active try a closed Sicilian
Grand Prix attack here we go Grand Prix
attack is on let's see what they do with
this okay let's take that night take
castled all right queenie 1/2 h forge f5
coming up coming up f5 can I get it in
pawn sack let's go for it let's go for
it
Knight g5 incoming whoa they are
absolutely crazy giving up their dark
square bishop they're looking to get
made it into one two can't be stopped
can't be stopped right there's no
stopping it nope there's no stopping it
they're just not going to move here
what's going on look at how quick that
happen right
I said they were crazy when they took
that when they gave up their dark square
bishop and this is these are the reasons
why these lights these dark squares are
vulnerable and now this is okay oh wait
they moved oh why did I take that one
off
okay back to tournament here we go I was
ready to grab on a little bit to eat
there while I was waiting
okay so let's try the care okay oh
that's what I like to see a quick
resignation
25:18 twelve still a lot of time the
tournament Oh
another quick that's it's a look out oh
man I was just trying to type can we get
three in a row three in a row no not
three in a row put that on in case
they're gonna go for Smith more what is
going on with this let's hit this Queen
Bishop takes Queen there we go
resignation no resignation clean iya
give a check
oh alright there's a lot of bad things
that could happen soon here real soon
what is going on that King is running
wild I'm okay I'll give that piece back
looking for mating - one two on f3 I'm
going to see it move the night they get
mated and if they don't it pick up more
material no resignation there we go
oh that's not me let's work a little bit
more for it let's get this in this
should takes night and then Queen here
is going to be made or this mate in one
- all right back to tournament
all right I can't get that typed in just
yet yeah it's another quick resignation
there we go no let's get that out of
there and accept and then reject that
einsteinium Z okay Knight takes all
right now what Bishop g5 night there
okay this is different okay let's happen
this dark square and now what this is a
little bit weird looking but I'm I'm
going to run with it
let's get castled f5 okay let's come
back light square weaknesses now you
could hop into that a light square h3
I'm not going to do that maybe maybe
this let's try that
getting that a f2 pond I could play
Bishop here I don't want to do that
though I want my queen on f6 maybe but
the knight move could actually be quite
strong there's a lot of pressure against
this I have to get rid of that Knight
very strong piece let's do that first
and my knight is a sad piece okay maybe
b5 how can I improve my position let's
take here dark squares okay let's take
that and let's break down this structure
a little bit I like the Knights in a pin
and now this is a wonderful square
wonderful square for my pieces let's
watch out for that night I'm going to
take with the pawn if there's a capture
I like that my King is more safe even
though these pawns look very ugly
they're going to be more safe than my
opponents is and let's let's double here
looking to take a couple times I'm on
that twice actually and okay let's take
this this is the more active rook and
what do I do here Oh Queen here and I
could support my rook with the g5
um like you get that pun
all right I'm missing anything 50
seconds my opponent is very I'm also on
the rook to I do let's uh let's just
come back to defend my back rank here
for a second
and let's do this and then double up
over here so how do they defend now
that's a good start
let's throw this in and then get my
queen central hit the rook I'm watching
this as well this is the pressure that
the rook has ah I missed that okay Queen
takes
let's take this with check and then
check this is very scary
am I missing something I'm probably
missing something 25 seconds each take
with my rook this is very very scary
right here got to go fast my opponent is
very very quick as well I just I know
from experience that they are very very
quick and I am NOT in a better position
at all here 16 seconds and it's run some
checks man and now I'm no be right
oh I mated Oh mate oh they had me I'm
just gonna run away I gotta take that
actually I couldn't take it
oh it's a draw haha they had made there
for a second Oh 53 to 42 that was a draw
oh okay let's do it again yes quick
resignation
alright 62 I have what kind of start is
that another resignation what is going
on I'm getting a lot of resignations you
could tell when it's like four I have
four more games in than anyone else so
there's a lot of quick resignations here
another one ah man I can't believe I
died a bullet there that would have been
painful I would have gotten pretty loud
there um okay so looking for the H for
square or each five square coz this
night isn't around
oh that's close to me um oh I already oh
this is actually winning cuz I could no
that's not right I get the Queen I was
thinking night there takes kink and then
check that's a pin Castle and pin good
thing to run with
there's probably made to somewhere
somewhere soon where is there me mate in
one and then two and I here's the threat
for me
this night is pinned there it is that's
a pretty cool mate back to tournament
alrighty so let's play solid against
this guy here another advanced variation
okay let's get my nights out let's offer
Queen exchange generally a good idea in
the Carroll f5 is under my control put a
question to this Queen see what it wants
to do okay and now let's get my knight
back here this I just want to get now I
want to be in a position to play
actually what am i doing
take this rook for a second change of
plans
over here
let's come back over here f5 is where it
belongs h3 is not good because of Knight
f5 okay now let's get this move in and
then I could even follow up with the c4
and then target this pawn that's what
I'm looking to do let's target it first
and okay well actually let's take let's
see if they do know okay this is the
newly opened file I have this square
available for my pieces let's do this
and then come back this could be very
annoying to deal with in the mean - oh
okay let's get my own night out of there
or my rook so I'm not in a pin back on
with this if the pawn pushes he gets
this square and it's not pushing why not
that's a free pawn now let's come back
incoming this square right here I'm
dropping that pond however but things
should still be right I like my Knights
and how they have a lot of possibilities
however my King needs some help here
needs some room need some breathing room
here so if pawn takes I recapture with
check that's nice I might want to throw
in this b6 move to kick the bishop away
maybe I should have done that previously
my bishop is around to watch over this
square my rook is being hit and it
doesn't have very many choices it's
trapped no it's not I actually have this
fork okay good I'll take that I will
take that okay this is check they
probably missed that detail so yes they
did back to tournament 112 7156 this guy
okay and we got the Scandinavian center
counter defense temple gaining moves
Bishop out night out get castled I'm
going to sack upon they could take d4
okay they're not going for it and now
this could be a very annoying pin this
is weakened now ecigs is the drawback
with that move they're weakened
weakening their King position
tremendously Knight takes pawn
[Music]
let's go for this it's a free pond and
my queen is very active very very active
right here so she can't be she can't be
tolerated on this square there's no
getting this Queen involved in the game
kind of have to just go with the Queen
exchange Queen takes pawn rook on the
open file pawn push there's nothing
happening here
not unless this Queen can maybe get over
here but that's not happening
so let's take let's watch over this pawn
I can't rely upon my knight to be kicked
away at any moment I'm reluctant to play
this pawn push because the knight has a
nice square here so now maybe I should
be doing that but let's let's not I'm
going to still be stubborn here with
watching over that I'd like to get this
pawn up to defend this and let's keep
this file closed and let's watch over
this guy I don't want to give it up King
to f1 getting my king a bit closer or
maybe just a c3 Knight c1 this should be
good
[Music]
c1 to d3 I think those are good moves to
be running with they have less than a
minute tuned up a lot of time here c12
d3 coming up watching over these squares
I'm okay with pawn takes my knight is a
there's nothing going on on this file
nothing back had happened this night is
under control
let's keep it under control is looking
for c4 and let's get my knight to this
square next g3 or e3 let's watch over
this first and let's lend support to it
let's go a different route and okay now
my knight is in checking distance
checking distance away rook here is a
move to be running with or Knight f2 to
e4 I'm slowly but surely slipping into
these weaknesses that my opponent is
leaving behind and now this night is out
of plane
be vulnerable night check Knight takes
rook takes on the seventh advance my
majority this is a four-on-three
majority on the Queen side 97 or 97 to
f5 94 grab here very little time now
this is coming with tempo pressure
against this point rook to this square
as well let's let's go for it they don't
have any time back to tournament 132 90
71 less than five minutes left in the
tournament this probably be the last
game last full game and look at the
center that I have okay they've
neglected their center and now I can
start pushing their pieces around so
this is not a good decision to be
running with this I'm developing and
watching over this the knight is already
to be trapped with h6 and now there's
some issues coming up this move there's
something with this move I think that
could be good Queen c7 oh man okay this
is well this is a week in square right
here so I want to get my knight there
maybe they gave up their light square
bishop light squares are weak Bishop c4
if Queen e2 maybe b5 okay I could just
win upon I was going to go there anyhow
now I'm just getting some material for
tricks discovered checks bishop pair
open position this is very good Bishop
can sit on d3 this night is out of play
of a half-open B file my queen is on the
Queen side can give checks over here as
well hitting the queen and the night
queen here is no good Bishop takes
Knight and I get the Queen for free very
few choices right now for my opponent
where to go with that Queen not very
many good choices at all
so there we go this is what I was
talking about
take the remove the defender with check
and then take the Queen okay
this is going to end quick Queen to c2
or a2 depending on what this rook
decides to do and then it's going to be
made probably on this square or this
square one of these two is going to turn
out to be may eat or die' to 45 seconds
for my opponent how much time is left
two minutes in the tournament two-minute
warning
35 seconds 34 hum they are not moving
they're just going to let this clock
tick
less than 20 these are my two moves
Queen c2 or queen the a to getting to
this square rook here I just take and
that's me
bishops cutting off the King there's no
coordination the rooks are disconnected
not a good situation
down material back to tournament 150 288
is not going to be any catching this is
this is the guy that's a second and
second place here Lee one two three four
five all right now let's go with this
maybe Bishop ace h6 okay I'm going to go
Queen to be one to watch over this and
stay out of the this file there might be
some issues with them without so now
here comes e4 e 4 is coming up with
tempo and this rook is unprotected on 88
the rook is unprotected on a important
detail what is that Queen doing
let's take takes and then trade light
square bishop s'
oh that's a blunder what am i doing
didn't take my bishop oh man that was a
free bishop they trusted me don't trust
me do not trust your opponent that was
awful that was a free bishop oh man okay
let's take this Oh rook here nope that
won't be good and ah
that would have been so painful okay
looking for f4 but not right away cuz
this pawn is pinned Oh
the term it's over oh what a game right
there Oh
that's crazy okay there it is the final
standings this was stick around if you
want to see me get beat up for some and
some other tournaments this is a much
weaker tournament when it's a lot
stronger I get beat up a real lot so
alright good games all this was recorded
type it out okay after the string it'll
be under the videos tab alright